question on the left right right over
here hi congratulations Ryan Tonya Hart
you know I love all of your shows you
know it's very interesting how you
managed to take iconic people in history
break them down and turn them into
something so human which is what you did
again how where does that come from how
do you do that I think he comes from the
writing I think that in the case of you
know people versus OJ and now Versace we
had incredible scripts Versace by Tom
Rob Smith who wrote them all and then I
think it's casting I think that we cast
people who loved these real life people
as much as we did and I think you can
feel the the love and the passion that
all of those actors had for characters
even in their darkest of moments and
their most unlikable of moments also in
the back of my left yes hi
congratulations I you know you gave this
very impassioned speech on stage about
what the project meant to you up so when
you were looking back at it and putting
pen to paper was this about that message
in the beginning or was this just about
telling the story well I never put pen
to paper because I didn't write a word
of this Tom Rob Smith wrote every script
but i but you know what I mean I do know
I mean it was it was a story that I was
passionate about very early on right
when we set up Oh Jay and we were
talking about making this an ongoing
anthological miniseries I met with Brad
Simpson and Nina Jacobson and I just
said I want to tell this story because I
was in LA five years when Andrew Cunanan
had started his spree and I really felt
that it was a story that needed to be
told the themes and issues that we
talked about in the show are as modern
as ever if not more so but was it more
important for you to tell the mechanics
of the story or again referring back to
what you said on stage was it more
important for those elements to come out
yeah sure I mean I'm always happy to
make a political statement you know
and everything that I do and I the
statistic that I said which was 1 in 1
in for LGBTQ Americans will be the
victim of a hate crime is true and
heinous and as a gay man who was told
that when I started off in the business
that I could not even write in 1998 a
gay character the idea that now 20 years
later I get to tell the story and
proselytize for my community is
important to me thank you sir you're
welcome
anybody else we're good congratulations
thank you guys thank you so much
[Music]